my next guest has multiple specials on
netflix of course you've seen him on
conan please welcome all the way from
india verdas
fierce thank you so much for for being
here yeah i have a show with that
it was no effort at all i walked six
feet from from the bedroom
over to this chair and and i'm happy to
be here it's the easiest
hat on yeah no work went into this
not at all right i am not wearing
underwear there's i haven't had a
haircut
in six months and this is uh yeah it's
pretty easy
are you growing the hair out i've been
growing out i'm in that awkward like i
just have like uh
it's like emo face right now i've seen
i'm in the
uh i think yeah i think i hate my
parents but i don't know like i'm in
that phase right now
so yeah we don't we still desperately
depend on them but
we hate them i listen to five indie
bands and you don't know any of them
that's the haircut basically we like
their first stop
yeah whatever the first thing was we
haven't heard it because our parents
won't let us but
you you saying did you go through an emo
phase
outside of the big emo phase that the
world is going through right now no
yeah yeah outside of this
six billion people existential crisis
that we live in right now
no it's been all right like i was
telling someone i think
comedians especially like those of us
who spend a lot of time on the road
we're pretty well trained for a lockdown
aren't we like we just
you know we're in our hotel all day we
come out for an hour
and even then we don't like the people
we meet and then we live for 10 minutes
and go back home
isn't that life right now for everyone
that's it you're on for 10 minutes
you're locked up in the hotel
it has been weird though not having
shows at night for me because
you i usually get away with like wasting
the entirety of the morning
it's like yeah the work is at night and
then 8 p.m rolls around
you're like oh i didn't do anything yeah
and then you have to kind of deal with
family and be like oh these people have
dreams as well
and lives that i have missed out on this
entire time
but that's that's been fun other people
other people
yeah are you going crazy a little bit
and not being able to
to travel yeah this is the longest i've
been
in one place in 15 years like a decade
or 15 years so it's
you know i've gotten to know my wife
again that's been interesting
uh you know like it's ray did you learn
her middle name yeah
no but we've unlocked like new levels of
fighting which is nice i i feel like
you know normally we'd fight and i'd
have to like go on the road or we'd
fight and i'd have to go
do a thing now we fight in this time to
plot revenge and [ __ ] man so it's it's
like
it's right yeah okay i'm so glad you
brought this up because i this has been
happy to me i'm locked out with my
girlfriend and i'll notice that
i'm fighting like just because i have
the time
to fight like before i would just give
up i'm like yeah
i gotta go on the road you win you she's
gonna win anyway so it's just like
yeah end it but now i'm i'm honestly the
other night i was like oh yeah you would
say that you're exactly like your
mom i don't know that to be true at all
i'm just trying to pass a thursday i
think also you you go through like five
reactions to what they say and then you
kind of go
ah covet and then it's done you know
where
yeah we're all saying stuff that we just
like we were fighting the other day and
she was like
you know what burn in hell which is
a very like that's a powerful thing to
say
you know when you're fighting about like
parmesan cheese or something like that
and i was just like
right this is cheese hell okay kobe
that's what this is and then you kind of
let that go but you could just use that
as a cop out for everything just like
it's listen yeah i cheated on you but
you know
covered man i'm gonna milk this thing
for at least three more years
like as long as i don't care if i'm
freshly vaccinated
i'm still milking this thing yeah are
you doing the like are you doing the
elbow when you meet people are you doing
like distant wave yeah yeah so a couple
of things i'm doing like the
the elbow bumps some people are going
for handshakes and i'm like no
yeah one guy the other day he was doing
um i was doing this like virtual show
and then he was a guy checking in
anytime he went to go listen
he would pull the mask off he'd be like
so we're just going to have you guys
come
in and out and then what was that yeah
like he could hear out of his mouth what
are you doing what's
what's the protocol bumps i mean we've
had the namaste for years right
and now there's like american people and
british people doing the namaste and i'm
like no
no you don't get to do it i'm sorry this
is i know there's a pandemic but i
no this is cultural appropriation
absolutely not we're not doing yoga
white people are wanting to do this for
so long like
without signing up for yoga you don't
get to do it no
right bowing can you just bow no
i don't know i feel like that's too much
respect
to show someone like yeah who's the last
person you met and you were like you
know what they deserve a bow
i can't think of like you know this
person is awesome
you know yeah maybe i haven't i haven't
found anyone bow worthy in a very long
time
yeah when the lockdown happened so you
know in
in in india we have you know household
help is a big is a bigger thing in india
right so everybody has like staff
that kind of lives with them in the
house i mean it's
i mean we learned that from from you
guys but you kind of forgot about it
along the way and we just kind of kept
it going but you you pay your staff in
america we had a lot of trouble
not paying the people that worked at the
house so then when the lockdown happened
we just
every indian person was like look at me
i'm cleaning my own kitchen and i'm
i'm doing my own dishes and i'm i'm
sweeping my own floor and i'm like
it took a global pandemic to make you
behave like
every european and every american in the
world right now there's
there's nothing special about you doing
dishes quit posting that [ __ ] on
instagram right now
i'm suspicious of people with clean
apartments i think clean apartments
should get shut down you see someone
cleaning they're prepping for a party
yeah i think so i think so they're
trying to get people out
is that not allowed over there are you
not allowed to have like gatherings and
like people over is that
not allowed but it's also america so
anything that's the rule people like
well it's my right so
there's a lot of states here that have
not locked down at all
like at all for the last six months like
they've locked down
but they've really never locked down
like florida never did a lockdown
also florida doesn't do a lot of stuff
that america does it's really its own
i wonder if india has a florida
equivalent is there a state
or a region that people are just like
this is
that really everything we're embarrassed
about the appendix in your body isn't it
florida
it's just never worked for anything and
you haven't been able to
don't need it yeah we don't even know
about it until it becomes a major pain
yeah it could destroy the rest no no
i i think i mean this is controversial
but
we feel about i feel like india and
pakistan feel about each other how you
feel about florida maybe that's the way
that this goes
okay you know like yes in fact you said
that yeah certain regions can be the
florida
like florida is your pakistan florida is
america's pakistan that should be the
flag
that should be the tagline welcome to
florida america's pakistan
i'm sure florida would love the
comparison yeah it is uh we have this
like
idea of of like everyone in india
indian accent at least in media here
that everyone is indian accent is a
genius yeah so anyone that's in a heist
movie which is cool when you were
in the show uh whissey cavalier spy
crime show you're in these like
three-piece suits you get to actually
kick ass you're not the guy
in the van which usually you get type
cast as you do that
yeah cause americans just hear that like
this guy's genius
yeah yeah or he's in the simpsons but
one of the two yeah
the thing you know the strange thing
with that is like i was thinking about
it the other day uh
i don't mind that accent like you know i
i know a lot of like
indian kids who grew up in america right
and who were like well i got bullied
because of that accent and it propagates
the wrong stereotypes and and i was
called up
and and sometimes you know there's a
billion of us who just sit back and go
hey man apoo isn't the indian with the
funny accent
like you are you know like i know a
billion people who sound like a poo
you know and it's not strange to us at
all but on whiskey it was kind of cool
to have an indian character who wasn't
eager to please and have his stuff
together and you know just doing numbers
and
this was just a guy who was bad with
people and and good with guns which
you know some some indians are i think
yeah it's just it's just cool to see
that to go against not
you know see every indian character
through the white perspective of what we
you know
stereotyping yeah i think so i think so
cause i really
really liked i think the first thing i
ever saw on you was uh your netflix
special
where right away you go this is this is
my accent and
for once to remember the quote i might
butcher it but
the indian accent is going to be
perspective and not
yeah i mean that's that's it's important
to me
and also just to show indians as
as flawed people or people who are in
doubt or people who
don't have their entire lives planned
ahead of them i
i would love to see an indian have sex
on american television and this is not
because i haven't seen an indian have
sex
or i haven't seen american television i
just have seen those two things
like we have a billion people we're
having sex
uh and and yet nobody i've never seen an
indian character hook up
on tv i've never seen that either right
they just don't show it i think this is
you should start doing this i think you
put on unsolicited self
tapes you edit yourself into already
famous sex scenes
yeah you basic instinct yourself
right now right you're already bottom
lips right now you just go across those
legs
just me with like a w with a cigarette
and then just two white cops on the
other end
who are being used instead of arresting
me which would be
yeah you know to be applauded as a hero
and a pervert
yeah i think so yeah this is the
direction as your new manager i would
love
to get you on tape and expose well this
was so much fun beer thank you so much
for joining
the show it's really nice talking to you
i don't think i ever got a chance to
really talk to you i've seen all your
stuff and this was this is a lot of fun
it was a lot of fun as well i hope to
see you soon and i i
i hope the gigs go well man like uh like
i hope you enjoy it and just eat it all
up i'm back
out there i'm i'm trying to get to india
so you're if your people want to follow
you
and they want to maybe uh if you're
starting this tour up this is happening
in january
in january uh i'm uh dave das on twitter
no not because i'm arrogant just veered
that's mistaken so i can do that
uh viewed us on instagram and on
facebook and yeah just come see the
shows and there's two or
three netflix specials out there there
are three netflix specials out
right um yeah and they're fun so yeah
because you're at home please check them
out i
really recommend them they're they're
really great and people have nothing but
time on their hands yeah
thank you so much thank you so much all
right see you